hello I'm lupita nyong'o and I play
Raksha the mother wolf in Disney's The
Jungle Book this is a grand reimagining
of the classic tale and I'm excited for
you to see the epic adventure on the big
screen in a brand-new way you will get
the most out of the wild and wonderful
world of the jungle book when you
experience it in imax here's a special
look at the movie in theaters april
fifteenth hello hi oh don't be scared
I'm not gonna hurt you are you alone
here I'm waiting for a friend you should
be here soon we should never be long
I'll keep you safe who are you
I know what you are I know where you
came from would you like to see ya
mostly men stay in their village but
sometimes they travel and when they do
their caves breathe in the dark they
call it the rat flower it brings warm
and light and destruction to all that it
touches
who is that the traveler protecting his
cub
sharekhaan ended the man's life the
Panther found the cub
and that cub was you I want him dead
the jungle is no longer safe
I return him to where he belongs
if you send it back to the man village
they'll ruin them they'll make a man out
of them
you will always be my son
I'm ugly
this is my home
you